we trained as illustrators at the
philadelphia college of art from there
we went over to Royal College of Art to
do our master's degree then I became a
waiter and he became a typographer and
then we our friend in Holland said well
if you're washing dishes in America why
don't you come wash them in Holland on
the way to Holland
we went in to back to London to visit
some friends and our present producer
Keith Griffiths who we actually went to
school with at the Royal College was
working at the British Film Institute
and he said why don't you guys propose
something for an experimental film as
there was an experimental wing at the
British Film Institute he said we do
experimental films he said we'll propose
something and we said publishing and we
had the crude but he we we made a we
drafted something in a couple of days
gave it to Keith and then went off to
live in Holland and about six months
later we got Keith called us and said
I've got you 9,000 pounds come back and
make your puppet film so we came we came
back and it was just literally learning
under fire we made a we fact we were so
intimidated by working with the puppet
because all we had was one of those
stupid little mannequins that you buy in
an art shop and we decided that since we
couldn't move the puppet and were so
unresponsive they we would make
everything move around it and then
create a highly subjective universe
around it this continued for quite a few
years working life
but eventually I think we started to get
a hold of our art craft by making a lot
of mistakes and it was just the two of
us and it's easy to fail when it's just
the two of us it wasn't until we got
hold of a magnet that we could not worry
about moving things around the way that
we've tended to always work was that the
puppets thrust work you can see we don't
have famous voices behind our puppets
for us the the puppets work best as the
mask with the mask you you have to read
it you have to interpret it and you know
it works much closer to dance where you
don't expect of dancers they don't talk
you read a ballet through but the
synthesis of gesture rhythm music the
choreography and decor with this we
always had the music upfront before we
even began so in a sense when you're
it's like you you get to know the music
so well that you know it comes out
through your fingers and as when you're
building that decors or working with the
puppets through all the time working
with your hands and your hands think